are different subcast of Muslim allowed
in Islam a question is different subcast
allowed in Islam in Islam there's no
cast
system Allah says in the Quran in is
number 17 verse number
70 Adam Allah has honored all the
children of Adam mean all the children
of Adam are equal in the sight of Allah
but Allah also says in chapter number 49
verse number 13
oh humankind we have created you from a
single pair of male and female and have
divided you into Nations and tribes so
that you shall recognize each other not
that you shall despise each other and
the most honored in the S of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala is the person who has
tawa the only way one human being can be
superior to the other human being is by
tawa is by pety is by righteousness is
by God Consciousness that the only way
and our beloved Prophet mam said that no
Arab is superior to a non-arab neither
is a non-arab superior to an Arab no
black man is superior to a white man
neither a white man Superior to black
man except the virtue tawa is the only
criteria which can uplift one human
being above the other there's no class
system in Islam now you ask me a
question that there are different groups
that are there you said this group that
group or whatever group that is there
see making sex in Islam is Haram Allah
said says in the Quran in Al Imran chter
number 3 verse Number
103 hold to the Rope of Allah strongly
and be not divided that means we have to
hold the Rope of Allah the Rope of Allah
is the Glorious Quran we have to follow
the Glorious Quran and the authentic
Hadith of mammad wasallam and be not
divided Allah says in Surah Anam chapter
number six verse number 159 that if
anyone makes sex in Islam oh Prophet you
have nothing to do with him Allah will
look after his Affairs on the day of
judgment so there are many verses in the
Quran we say that making sex in Islam is
prohibited so any sex in Islam is
prohibited you have to be United
following the Quran and the Sunnah
making different
organizations making an
organization Islamic Center Islamic
propagation Center or so and so
Foundation making an organization for a
particular work is allowed but that
doesn't mean a person belonging to
Islamic propagation Center or to Islamic
Research Foundation is a person more
closer to Allah no the work you do makes
you closer to Allah ta so making
organizations forming an organization
forming a jamaat to do a particular work
whether it be in dawa whether it be in
education whether it be in that say
Quran is no problem but you can't make
sexs in Islam so making an organization
for particular activity is no problem
but making sexs and Division in Islam by
forgetting Islam in that this group is
so and so better closer this style is
right the style is only Allah and his
one way Islam is only one there are no
two division in Islam hope that answer
the question